hi reg how are you this morning I'm
doing well how are you doing good what
did you what did you see how did you
know the severity of that injury well I
mean you've seen this play probably a
dozen to thousand times you know a
simple alley-oop and when the play
happened you know it's interesting
because Kevin Harlan who is just inches
away from me to my left probably had the
best angle of it
so when Kyrie through the back screen
alley-oop to Gordon if you look at the
play there wasn't a lot of contact but
it's the way he fell that Kevin saw so
Kevin's initial reaction if you listen
to the broadcast was oh my god Gordon
Haywood has broken his leg and as soon
as he says that our cameraman that's
when the shot that everyone saw when his
foot nourished you what kind of office
foot and so it was turned backwards and
that's when you started hearing all the
gasping the murmurs in the crowd but to
me the biggest thing was the reaction of
the Cavaliers bench and their players
because that's when they started like
throwing their hands up in the air and
in in the heat of it you could see
Gordon Hayward motioning to Monty
McCutchen the official like look at my
foot look at my foot and I applaud Monty
McCutchen in the time just calling the
timeout because he needed immediate care
at that point in time so you know it
happened all in a matter I'm sure for
him probably felt like minutes but it
was seconds all this transpired within 3
to 5 seconds of him motioning to ma knee
to him throwing his hands up to the I
mean it's a crowd alone that's what I
kept mentioning because you could hear
the small whispers amongst 18,000 and
then you know you saw Dwayne Wade
kneeling and praying and guys were in
tears because at the end of the day it's
competition yes but we are brothers in
arms' we all know how hard it took for
us to get to this level
and safety and his well-being is first
and foremost and I hope for a speedy
recover one thing we did find out in
talking with Kyrie as I was coming back
on the court at halftime they reset it
right there they had to distract him and
reset his foot and that's to me the
probably the most painful thing so when
you see him screaming on the floor
that's probably when they were resetting
there your body goes into shock I'm
gonna guess yeah yes because I could see
I knew the severity of it when I saw the
Cavs players that that they walked away
it was like Kevin where Louisville
during the NCAA tournament you got that
feeling that there was something really
horrific there correct and we were
trying to think of leg injuries
especially in basketball and Kevin ware
came it came to mind Paul George when he
had that token late in that exhibition
game for Team USA in Las Vegas Shaun
Livingston when he kind of blew out his
knee and you know you think about all
the times that and you've played this
game for so many years in basketball how
many times a simple L you play you just
land awkward because it wasn't a lot of
contact just landed awkward yeah you
can't place the blame on anything
because that was a design play I mean
every team has plays like that where you
throw an alley-oop from a back screen he
said his man up perfectly
fake like he was coming up and he had it
he just failed the wrong way and you
know I texted him you know and told them
and this too shall pass there's light at
the end of the tunnel you know you'll be
come back bigger and stronger and faster
than this and I'm glad he got back and
told me you know thanks reg I appreciate
it so he seems like he's in good spirits
but I'm sure this is gonna be a long
recovery I know you gotta catch a flight
I want to ask you about what you saw
though in the game itself as as we move
forward with the regular season let me
start with Cleveland and LeBron he said
he was out of shape he sort of played
old man basketball but he still put up
unbelievable number
I again I said this on the air I like to
pick up stellar surrounding LeBron Jeff
Green Derrick Rose had some vintage
Derrick Rose moments last time
especially in some of this drives so I
like the veteran presence that's
surrounding LeBron you know for a guy
that's out of shape he was in assists
away from a triple double so it's kind
of scary if he does find myself to get
in shape what's gonna happen and for the
Boston Celtics now it's really really
going to be the Kyrie Irving show and
these young guys are going to have to
step up and we saw that in the second
half especially the rookie Jason Tatum
had 14 points in that second half didn't
shoot the ball particularly well in the
first but jaylen Brown I think it's
going to be a star on this Boston
Celtics team because now both of those
guys are going to get the minutes
because of the injury to Hayward but
it's a young team but this is your
opportunity to shine reg thanks for
calling in and safe travels to Oklahoma
City
I appreciate the I better thank you
that's Reggie Aloysius Miller calling in
that was nice the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you